eine Frau schneidet sich die Haare ab
mitten im Europaparlament am Rednerpult
die schwedische EU-Abgeordnete ab ihr
als salani ist das Haare ab mit der
Schere und das bedeutet für sie das
bedeutet im Moment für tausende Frauen
weltweit Solidarität mit den iranischen
Frauen die seit Wochen so mutig
protestieren für ihre Rechte und gegen
Kopftuchzwang ein Protest der die ganze
Welt mitreißt
sie gehen für ihre Freiheit auf die
Straße
demonstrieren unter Lebensgefahr haben
genug von Unterdrückung und Tugend
Terror die mutigen Frauen im Iran jetzt
gehen auch die Schüler und Studenten auf
die Straße eine Studentin hat jetzt eine
Sprachnachricht an Bild geschickt mit
Bild zu sprechen bedeutet für die junge
Frau Lebensgefahr sie könnte dafür von
den Sicherheitskräften des Regimes
gefoltert oder getötet werden Bild hat
deshalb ihren Namen geändert Shirin 22
Jahre alt studiert in tehan wurde in den
letzten Tagen Zeugen der grausamen
Gewalt des horror-regimes
willst du einfache Freiheitsrechte dann
wirst du einfach misshandelt diese
Menschen sind einfach krank
die schlagen vergewaltigen und
misshandeln uns Maße Amini war nicht die
einzige und letzte die hier misshandelt
wurde wir sind es
sattinnen studieren an der Freien Uni im
Norden von theaan dort hat der unirektor
DR halidi den Zutritt von
regime-anhängern und den Schlägertrupps
verboten
er wurde dann seines amtsen
junge Leute wie ich oder auch Kinder die
hier im Iran Leben haben die Geduld
verloren und Leiden jetzt wo die ganze
Welt und sieht und hört
rosa
immer lecker
jetzt wo die ganze Welt und sieht und
hört jeder der unsere Schreie hört soll
sich hinter das Volk Stellen
Worte von einer mutigen jungen Iranerin
seit fast drei Wochen demonstrieren
Iraner gegen das islamistische Regime
der Mullahs trotz Lebensgefahr gehen Sie
auf die Straße und in Deutschland nichts
gähnende Lehre vor der iranischen
Botschaft keine Proteste niemand erhebt
die Stimme gegen das Unrechtsregime in
Deutschland wo gegen alles und gegen
jeden demonstriert werden darf Schweigen
währenddessen sterben im Iran weiter
Menschen für ihre Freiheit offizielle
Bilanz bislang mindestens 133 Tote und
unzählige Festnahmen
[Musik]